I feel like I've known you a long time
in a long time how many do we meet years
ago on the old one of the old shows I
did your show that shall not be named on
NBC night show yes late-night talk show
that you did good name that show proud
of that show um and uh that was seven
years ago and it was my very first talk
show and it was it was amazing because I
was so talk shows are weird just for
people like it's a very strange and
weird format to get used to and I was
completely green I had just done like
ten episodes of The Office and they're
like you're gonna do Conan O'Brien and I
was so I oh you were just totally my
idol and I was so beside myself and it
was crazy it was in New York City and
that's crazy theater and you come out
and like the ban is so loud and the
lights are swirling and the cameras are
moving the audience is like and I'll
never forget this I I came and I sat
down and you did this thing it's like I
was looking around like I didn't know
where to look and you were like you did
this thing you literally did this thing
as you sat down I know you remember that
I don't remember I didn't do that with
other people but maybe I saw that you
were kind of I think you did you know so
I guided you into these like words right
like it those beautiful blue pools of
love yeah and no it was it really saved
me do you do that a lot don't I don't do
that to anybody it was like a Jedi mind
trick yeah I think I probably saw you
know okay he's wandering he's confused
and I said again let's write try to I
tried to lure you in look like ant let's
do not yet ready I'm like oh haha
that's exactly how it went yeah exactly
we've recreated now I don't didn't do
that holding the moon are you holding
them
let me help you it's tricky you are so
popular now hugely people are you're
very young
I'm enormous and you've you've kept it
all in perspective yeah I'm amazing yeah
I hold the moon up next question
fans of viewers get tattoos of Dwight on
their body do they not this is true this
is a recent phenomenon in the last
couple years every once in a while like
on Twitter or Facebook though I'll see
these photos that get sent in and there
are quite a lot of people out there
supporting Dwight tattoos and it's how
do you feel about that are you okay with
it's very flattering and it's it's it's
very very kind but I really I really
worry for them and not not for the like
they're mentally but just more like like
what's gonna happen in like the year
2043 yeah you know when they're old you
know and they've got Walker's or some
like that and they have to explain to
their grandchildren like well there was
this thing called television 22 minutes
shows that had these commercial breaks
in between and on it was this very
bizarre character with an enormous head
played by Rainn Wilson named Dwight and
I loved this character so I got it
tattooed on my calf and I'm tired in my
calf it's crazy we have these are real
these are off the internet
these are absolutely goofy oh yeah I
don't know oh my god okay that's a thigh
I like that's a sort of a saucy I'm next
to a zombie yeah there you are you've
got some company there and there's
another one coming soon about oh wow
assistant regional manager and that's
going right up to the buttock there's a
beautiful womans thigh you can tell
right there and I just wonder like does
you know if she's making lovely love
with her man friend and like he's
mounting her and you think about this um
but he's looking down he's seeing my
face you know it's so weird and I wonder
if he's good good
if he if he would get like an Angela
tattoo my love interest from the office
tattooed on his thigh and then they
would merge you're dangerously ill just
I think about the tie things are the
same things we have you have you have
time to end in I think we have a few
examples there's one I actually kind of
like
we're wearing a space caller and then
this one I wasn't so crazy about no that
looks like I'm entering re-entering
orbit and getting burned up I think you
look like the Joker unintel II know what
Andy has that one that's Andy Andy yeah